the jurgen experience
oh my god yeah it's the that's how it
would go at the comedy cellar like
just like this [ __ ] dunce that's
right here it would count
did i hear that the the commie seller is
like seriously
has a social justice warrior infestation
like they need to like spray the place
oh i don't i mean when i've been there
it hasn't been like that i mean they've
been there been people writing about it
they've been
i mean it's like the comedy cellar is
like the main hub
of culture now it's the main hub of
wokeness yeah i mean it but it's also
like the
the main battlefield of oldness where
it's like louis came
and they were protesters and then i
couldn't sit at the table
and i because it's like all right i mean
yeah i don't think it's pull your dick
out yeah i told
louie to put dick out and she was a hero
i was i was quoting all these tweets uh
that were
talking about and articles that were
written hero she was heroic
i think i think someone sent me a louis
article today i think there's just
fatigue at this point
yes i think people are just like taught
like what's he i don't okay like try to
find a new
stormy daniels article yeah everybody's
like enough
yeah try we thought it was gonna work it
didn't work yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't give a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he
doesn't care
[ __ ] dude justin martindale was and i'll
never forget he's in the [ __ ] hallway
of the comedy store as
flamboyant as he could ever be yeah and
he goes that's our monica lewinsky
she's gonna take him down i'm like good
luck stormy daniels yeah i'm like good
luck
yeah that ain't gonna do [ __ ] yeah so
what's the worst thing
that comes out of this that he [ __ ]
her or that he paid her to keep quiet
and she didn't keep quiet
what's the worst thing do we think he
doesn't [ __ ]
yeah it's all different strains i'm like
we knew he was gross
no one cared the only way that
you'll it goes he raises taxes yeah or
then he'll lose his base or you uh
raise his taxes on lower middle class
people and if he if he
like doesn't stand by his abortion step
but otherwise
all the donors are sticking with them
everyone's sticking with them what
happened
yesterday there was a new abortion
ruling was it in alabama
yes that's basically i
personally believe it's going to
backfire you think so
yeah because i think people the thing
that that's always been true is
republicans were against
uh abortion and they would go like we
and they never
got to repeal it right right i think
they're going to repeal it and then
people are going to go like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa this is crazy
if you don't want to get abortions fine
but you can't uh change a law
based on a lot of times not even a
plurality
of of uh you know like in general
elections like in the general
presidential election like
it's not even the majority of the
country that elects the president now
who vote was this something that the
people of alabama no it's the
it's the government like the the state
legislature that is a slippery slope
yeah and it's like you're going you're
doing 99 years in jail if you get
if you give an abortion or get one yeah
that's what it is now
yeah that's what it's gonna that's the
law that they passed
i just personally believe that i mean
i'm obviously hopeful
but it's a bit like nah that's too far
it's a bit like
when they made clinton testify and
people are like
ah that was too that was like the the
the
two too far uh the a line was crossed
when they made clinton testify about a
sex life and it was like
we don't like that we understand that
you wanted to rebuke the guy but don't
make the pres
and i feel like i'm hoping and i believe
it's true
uh that it will be too far afield for
moderate people i hope you're right and
it's just it's very dangerous when you
just decide that no one
can do it anymore based on a few
people's
decision that is going to affect the
millions of people that live in alabama
well abortion laws are odd because it it
the assumption is the reason
christians want to outlaw it is because
they think
god is going to say what's with your
vote
on that i saw that you voted for
abortion what like you want to kill
babies yeah so you want to kill babies
like well no i didn't i didn't kill
anybody
but you voted for it's like they don't
want to live in a country where that's
legal
having said that if you google the
worldwide rights of abortion
it's not legal everywhere which
surprised me because i was like where is
it
what is america's uh where do we stand
within the rest of the world
and there are not a ton of countries but
there's a
there's i think it's illegal in a
quarter of the world
wow um if not more well abortion is one
of those things where it's like
okay when does it bother you it doesn't
bother me at all if you're two days
pregnant
doesn't bother me at all bothers me a
little if you're four months pregnant
bothers me a lot if you're five or six
bothers me a lot
if you look really pregnant you get an
abortion it's like what it
what is that is that a baby that would
be viable outside the womb
because it's one of those it's it's
something that people just have a
deep discomfort about when discussing
even if you're a supporter of it if you
just discuss the actual
reality of what it is what the act is
what this
surgical procedure is and it makes
you know it it's not it's it's not
nothing
that's the thing it's not nothing right
like and and i think that one of the
indicators that it's not nothing
and i'm pro pro choice as i yeah like
um you're right-wing joe everybody knows
that
so i'm so far right i go the other way
i'm left um the
back side the i actually do want to talk
about that uh
the the presumption about you um that
you know the one of the indicators is
when people talk about even getting an
abortion
they are they always whisper about it
yeah and i don't know if it's because
of the stigma or because they it's kind
of not nothing
yeah it's a it's a personal thing too i
don't think they want to discuss it with
other folks
but i wouldn't care if you got if i got
a cyst removed i mean if that's the
the indication just that yeah it's just
a medical procedure and again
pro-choice have at it yeah i'm sure
i've never i don't i haven't had any
abortions that i know of
um but i don't i don't know at what
point i'd be like ah
and these attitudes about it about the
taboo of discussing it though it impedes
rational discourse and impedes your
ability to talk about things and
communicate about them
because you have to have this very rigid
opinion that you're always
pro-abortion pro-women's rights women's
right to choose which i am it is but
we're still
talking about a real thing and that real
thing is killing
a thing that would grow up to be a
person and that's why people freak out
about it and to pretend it otherwise
is just disingenuous louis was the first
one i heard talk about that on stage in
a in a way that was funny where like if
they think they're murdering babies down
there yeah i'd protest too
yeah if i thought they were if there was
a place that i thought these people are
murdering babies right i'm out there
every day yeah
he's like i don't care i personally
think they are murdering babies
i don't care
you